hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so in this video i would
like to talk about sprt and bb ig guys
what is happening on those two stocks is
amazing so we having here a squeeze
situation coming from the regular shot
but especially coming from the synthetic
shot and i'm going to show you in this
video how to find those potential
squeezes and how to play it so let's get
into it
[Music]
okay first where should i start here i
think that everything is uh starting
from the synthetic short interest so we
can have a look for example at bbig
so you can see that when you take all
the option market open interest and you
convert it into shares you can see that
here the maximum synthetic short so
considering all the uh call options are
finishing in the money so this is very
easy to have is 87 so it grew from 55 to
75 to now 87
so this is absolutely massive all right
so this is the first information that we
are having here we then check the
regular short and we can see that the
total maximum short interest if uh so
this is not bb-8 yes this is sprt if
sprt goes to
100 we will have 100 of synthetic short
interest so this is the first
information this is how we spot those
potential short squeezes so i'm checking
this with many stocks so for example you
can check bbig i found this one
yesterday
so here if i get the synthetic short bam
then i just refresh my data sorry it was
not the correct spot so you can see here
we are at 45
so this is when you apply the delta and
we can go up to 66 so the first
information is that we have some gamma
we can go from 45 to 66 percent
uh and we have 18 of regular shots so
the total shot is right now 63 and it
can go up to 85 so this is you know
absolutely massive again so everything
starts from here so bbig was given to me
by a member of my discord yesterday uh
when it was trading at four and i
immediately spotted that there was
something here and i posted here an
alert as you can see guys here i
basically you know mentioned that
potentially we could go higher at this
time this was trading at 4 20. it is now
in after hours trading around 775 so
this was the alert i gave so it was at 4
20 4 30 and i said that the first target
is 7.75
and in one hour guys look what happened
in only one hour we went from 420 so
we're here actually we reached the
target in after uh hours so right now i
think that it's good to unwind 50 of
this position and keep it for a stronger
move and i think that this will keep
going higher uh the reason behind is
that i only i just check where this uh
short interest is coming from you can
see that most of it is coming from here
the
five strike and when you check which
maturity
is actually the biggest one here you can
see that bam so this is september have
17 7 000 options
and
you can see that
here october i have 45 000 and gen 22 40
000 so you can see that basically 90 of
this short interest is coming from a
maturity that is october and half
january so i think this so the pressure
will still be here until at least the
15th of october so i don't see a reason
why this would stop so i'm gonna try to
give you some cool strategies to play
this quiz already did yesterday uh so i
gave you also sprt guys
sprt was spotted here so for the same
reason we have a massive synthetic short
on those two stocks that are actually
very similar so let me show you this
again so here i can show you a bit of
the shortlist i'm building i'm trying to
identify the best way to spot a squeeze
so for now what i see is the max
synthetic short is the most important
criteria we can see that for bbig and
sprt we have around 70. so this one is
now 85 this was yesterday's data more
than 60 percent of synthetic short
interest as a comparison amc has 22
which is a lot as well but those two
they have small market caps around 400
million usd and a massive maximum
synthetic short so this is creating a
gamma plus we see on the charts so this
is when i gave you guys the alert for
example sprt i gave it at so what was
the level let me show you that again
okay so it was trading at 11.3 on the
24th of august and i gave you this alert
because i associated what i saw on the
option market
with the breakout with technicals so you
can see that here we are having a strong
resistance at 11 roughly and we broke it
so whenever we broke it i knew something
was happening so i posted this alert and
i will keep doing this i will try to
improve
my spreadsheets to spot this even faster
i have many ideas but i still need to
elaborate how to build a trustful
indicator about those quizzes and
it would for sure use the volume
daily volumes i'm building it right now
it would use uh the maximum synthetic
short the market cap and i'm gonna try
to associate all of this and try to you
know see what is the most likely short
shares that have been covered and for
example when you see that the maturity
of the synthetic shot is coming from
october this tells us that we have
one more crazy month to come i think uh
so then we're gonna try to identify the
levels where to take profits i told you
guys on sprt to exit yesterday
which was mostly followed if you guys
want to have a look you know yesterday
so basically uh
sprt okay it's time to fully unwind this
trade and it was training at uh 40 at
this time then it went to 65
great
but then it came back to 27. so this is
you know the timing is very important
here and i'm very happy to see that
everybody yesterday was here sharing the
gains so you can have a look at that
it's in the free area i'm so happy when
i see this because this is the purpose
of this channel is the purpose of my
discord is to share the knowledge that i
have i'm still learning this is a bit
new for me i was not doing that when i
was working as a professional trader i
have an extended knowledge of options
but i'm discovering everything about how
to play a squeeze but it looks like you
know there are many opportunities and
i'm gonna try to keep improving uh my
skills about that with you and this is
the project i'm having and i'm super
happy to see that things are working
well so far what can i say yes let me
show you what we can do so for now i
prefer bbig because there is much more
room on the upside you see sprt reached
to me when i check the chart on the
weekly it reached kind of you know the
targets all right so my target was
between 23
22 and 43 so i i told you guys this
yesterday and then i would have exited
my full position at 43 personally it
went slightly higher but right now i
think that maybe we can try to enter
again here there is a trade to do just
you know above so now 22 is support so
maybe buying around 22 23 with the stop
loss around 19 you know just below the
support and just above and let's see
this can go higher but the best here is
to play options because uh you don't
have a stop loss and your uh loss is
limited so it's the best thing with
those very fast moving stocks for bbig i
think that the potential is huge i think
we can go much higher
but once again it can dump right away so
here options are to me better so what i
would do
bam you go on options and bbig i would
go on the 15th of october for example to
give it a bit some time and you know
just bang the six
strike calls on the october maturity so
the volatility is 220 but the realized
volatility is 180 so it's not that
overpriced and you don't have much
choice here so you know just spending
some premium here 170 us dollars and if
this stuff goes to 20 you can make up to
uh 1 400 us dollars so it's a very nice
risky wood trade and i think that once
again like i showed you guys on bbig
the shorts come
mostly from uh october so here we can
see here we checked the five strike we
can check this one and this one so the
7.5 and 10 strikes
same thing as you see 26 000 the biggest
one is gen 22 26 000 so i don't see a
reason why this dynamics would actually
stop and once again we have room so i'm
bullish here but i would be careful with
buying shares because you don't know
where to put your stop loss so i would
go once again to the option market as it
is better to play this kind of trades
all right guys so that's it for me uh
i'm gonna keep updating you with
everything that i found thank you so
much for posting in the comments your
ideas i'm checking all of them and once
again i'm gonna come back guys with some
solid techniques and
indicators i would try to find the
potential squeezes and let's see what we
can do here so thanks for watching this
video guys and please don't forget to
click on the sub like and bell button so
you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to shore i see you guys